self-development depression is something
that you talk about what's that
essentially let's say you're a normal
person or you know about
self-improvement it's like oh yeah like
go to the gym but eventually you find
the space online you start finding the
books of self-help and everything some
people seem to get stuck in level one
and I think that a fair amount of like
healthy people seem to Breeze past this
stage it's only because of mental health
that they're stuck in stage one which is
that they know what they should be doing
they just can't seem to do it so for
these people for example they would have
had an idea let's say it's exercise and
they'll be like oh yeah like today's the
day I'm gonna exercise you know it feels
really relevant then they'll look back
and be like wait it's been three weeks
since I watched that motivational video
and I said I was going to exercise again
they fall straight into the same
patterns we could grab this person take
them inside the gym with us make them do
the best work out of their lives they're
so hyped and everything they're not
going to come again for like the next
month and it's this self-improving
depression because they are now in the
space of hearing about people like me
and even you yourself who have made
progress and we're talking about you
know the Fantastic like stuff that comes
from this and everything and they don't
get to enjoy that they just can't seem
to get consistent in any of the habits
and it's a very very depressing and like
scary place to be